you are enjoying her in theaters right
now in life of the party and then
available for streaming this Friday on
Netflix her new movie Ibiza or Ibiza if
you want to nitpick with the way you
talk Spanish good to see you Gillian
Jacobs great to see you
well is that it did I how do I say it is
it no you okay in the film we say Ibiza
because we're Americans and then people
from Europe say Ibiza
but yeah it's either which one
Ibiza yeah yeah why do we look at you
play that place it's very famous for
every big EDM DJ plays yeah that's what
our movies about exactly you guys come
on great movies about Mike Delph oh you
didn't know he like took a couple months
off and Cambridge wasn't all of him he
takes mental time off I wish that were
true all the time but because you're
here he'll be paying attention oh my god
I'm so honored seriously the only times
that he's paid attention in the last two
weeks is when you're here Gillian and
when we talk sports betting that's now
apparently more prevalent in the dude
look at that grin really appreciate the
grin and you know this is not your first
rodeo here on this show well since you
last were here Kris Brockman over there
has advanced as a human being in such a
way Haley yes because if you recall last
time you were here mm-hmm you were kind
enough to rummage through the desk
underneath these underneath desk area
there was a lot to rummage through well
I mean what was that we're showing it
right now on the television there you
are yeah there I am and you took out
what you took out an absurd number of
dress shirts and yeah food items that's
the most concerning thing to find
underneath a Halloween peeps oh those
aren't good the day you buy it I think
what was the grand total number of shots
well yeah at least it does yeah so where
do you keep your clothing now well I had
him in the closet I thought I do have a
couple over here but yeah not as many as
these
well you have advanced as a human being
you have a you have a girlfriend
for as long as how long have you had
your girlfriend two years oh my goodness
how do you feel was I the inciting
incident for all this change in growth
just say yes Chris yes oh I'm so proud
you're a factor huh
should I get like a life makeover show
on Bravo or something you don't have
time oh no I know I don't have time I
mean what's going on with you yeah
you're right but it's a girl can dream
everybody's dream to have a show on
Bravo well I'll never forget again that
it was a few years ago that I go to my
Twitter feed and you responded to
something that I tweeted out mm-hmm and
everybody's like oh my god you've got to
get Gillian on your podcast you've got
and this was way back at way by NFL
Network yeah and then we you know
exchanged pleasantries you did in fact
come on the podcast did and now here you
are on the second version of this show
it's been my great honor it's been my
great honor
well Gillian wondered why we don't call
the downs chances yes that was my great
innovation that I brought to the game of
football well cuz then I did in fact
then do an entire highlight on Thursday
Night Football doing that yes and it
made it made sense made more sense
that's a third chance and long yeah I
mean why still no one has explained to
me why they're called downs still years
years later I still don't understand do
we know we still don't have the answer
see I wanna know if it could if it takes
that long to come up with an answer you
know it's not a good term down chances
it you're like I get it you have this
many chances to advance this far I
understand football now you're grilling
again I love it
does he smile this often or am i it
depends on his medication
oh really yeah I think so today it's
sports betting legal in the state of
California yeah is that yeah yeah it's
coming did you not hear about the
Supreme Court ruling that happened last
week yeah or that no no yeah the Supreme
Court ruled that New Jersey in other
states that had not been already
grandfather
like say Nevada mm-hmm could now in fact
undertake sports gambling because they
were they said a federal rule preventing
it was unconstitutional I think I got
that right right you got are you setting
up a website perhaps I think me and
Chris are gonna open our own little book
with an idea for a TV network zone zone
channel I'm gonna proffer to say that
you and your significant other yes have
watched football on a red zone channel
at some point in time so many times I
couldn't even count okay so imagine
instead of where the red zone would be a
channel showing all different sporting
games but through the prism of how much
money you can make based on this play or
that play okay I'm now understanding it
I'm now understanding it and will you
have as caffeinated a host on the bet
zone channel as you do on the red zone
channel IV of caffeine yeah how quickly
can you talk to be intelligible
have you met gamblers no but I'm saying
you as the host if you're gonna be
hosting the bet zone channel right
you'll be like here we're going from
this thing that's happening right now in
Atlantic City and then we're going I'm
shooting off a pig or something like
that well that is in many ways gambling
yes that is happening okay and so the
short answer to your question is sports
gambling legal in California is not yet
not yet because I'm assuming every state
he's gonna see some revenue from this
sort of yeah what was like gillian
jacobs here in the Rich Eisen show again
Ibiza cracked ready for downloading on
net Netflix coming up on Friday well
then I'm sorry I can't stop life of the
party in theaters near you right now
what was last time you made a bet on
anything
I've never bet in my life come on oh no
I never have I've never drink I've never
heard
second yeah really correct I've never
had alcohol in your life in my life I've
never done a drug okay I've never taken
a pill recreationally and I've never bet
so what's your vice you have some Vice
don't you no I just have just this ball
of tension inside of me that just grows
and grows and grows I have nothing I'm
always sober it's a terrible burden huh
yeah have you ever been to Las Vegas
Nevada
I have so you never even bet on red
black nothing on the roulette nothing on
the spinning wheel nothing I've observed
others um no I'm very frugal as well so
to me you know I learned the house
always wins is that something that
people say yes they do yeah so I figured
I'll learn that lesson
losers say that Gillian the proprietors
of the you're not you're not part of the
target audience I'm not your demo but
you know before we met I was not
watching the red zone so I can be won
over okay as a viewer okay I've come to
enjoy watching sports because of you so
I could come to enjoy watching other
people gamble you're not a lost cause
knows what you're saying I'm open so do
you drive the speed limit yes I do come
on I know one time when I was new to
California I accidentally made a right
turn on red at a stop sign where you
couldn't make a right turn and I got a
ticket so that's all I've got
that's like the extent of and I didn't
do it I didn't intentionally break the
law do you walk when the hand is oh the
orange hand or not I wait in Los Angeles
in New York City I will J walk but in LA
that you will get a ticket for that
that's true they're not messing around
my wife has been ticketed for jr. really
yes well you're in and I think was in
Santa Monica
they're the worst and I lived there they
were there Santa Monica is the worst for
that they wait confirmed so do you're
confirming yes I got stopped seconded I
got off it easy oh gosh how did you get
off of yours I'm an ex-cop I just
totally smile do you see the smile just
smile
well money well spent
thank you better on that than on the
bedding zone mama needs a new pair of
jeans you've seen how he got those teeth
all right let's talk about your multiple
projects here that's Ibiza being
streamed on Netflix you you gave a
little glimpse of what it's about so
what what can people expect when they
expect three friends played by myself
Vanessa Bayer and Phoebe Robinson who go
on a trip to Spain I see a DJ at a club
I fall for him I follow him to Ibiza and
and hilarity ensues and hilarity and
hilarity ensues I'm really proud of this
one I think it's a really great fun
comedy adventure romance okay all right
romance I should say is it true that
Robb Stark yes is this gentleman yes I
have never seen game of well I've seen a
little bit of game I know what are we
doing what is he know what in the holy
heck has happened I know I didn't know
who he was I also know one warned me
that the man like runs 20 miles a day so
he showed up on set and he is a very
muscular gentleman and I had to be in
see it you see how nervous I am on
screen that's all genuine no acting
required I'm just babbling and he's very
muscley I immediately started working
out for the first time in my life upon
Richard at base camp
yes he's Robb Stark apparently he is
indeed there was one things from when we
when we were seeing and we're like wow
that there's Robb Stark he would deal
with a lot of maps on the show that's
see that's very strange and then life of
the party I mean to be involved
something with Melissa McCarthy and Maya
Rudolph and some competing you know
Julie Bowen women is equally as
hilarious as you I'd say funnier but
it's not true you're very kind you are
you are in you are in that rich realm
Gillian Jacobs complement that one time
I went on Conan O'Brien show and I went
to sit down and my ring became lodged in
the seat and I had to sit on my hand for
the entire but now this is this is
equally embarrassing that my bracelet
flew off it's all good I shouldn't wear
magnetized jewelry and that's why you
the life of the party it's all good okay
Gillian Jacobs you are a delight I love
having you here I love being here please
come back any time you want yeah I would
happy to do maybe commentary on a sport
for which I know nothing about perhaps
you'd like to send me to a sporting
event would you do that yeah seriously
absolutely done we will we will
brainstorm right now the problem is you
see the people with whom I must storm
the brain the three of you can come up
with one idea okay do you want a co-host
the bet zone channel you're not you're
not gonna get to do that what do you
mean you could maybe do it in Vegas as
like a encourage my dream yeah okay we
could do it as like maybe like an
affiliate station in Vegas would pick us
up right done okay Gillian Jacobs on
Twitter good to see you good to see you
you got a go stream Aviva on Netflix
this Friday and go seed
life-of-the-party in a theater near you
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience